i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest the
democratic party is trying to replace
the current
electorate with new people more obedient
voters from the third world but they
become hysterical because that's that's
what's happening actually let's just say
it that's true
if look if this was happening in your
house your parents adopted a bunch of
new siblings and gave them brand new
bikes
you would say to your siblings you know
i think we're being replaced by by kids
that our parents love more that's tucker
carlson's summary of the great
replacement theory a trendy conspiracy
theory that was echoed in ongoing
comments from republican members of
congress such as matt goetz and elise
stefanik of new york she's run campaign
ads accusing the democrats of planning a
permanent election insurrection by
granting amnesty to 11 million illegal
immigrants who will overthrow our
current electorate and create a
permanent liberal majority in washington
the great replacement theory is
spectacularly wrong in asserting that
the government is really going to create
millions of new citizens overnight or
that in the unlikely event that that
actually happened they will be obedient
in voting for democrats tucker and his
pals are also really worried about the
government giving all sorts of new and
better and shinier stuff to immigrants
but he's got it backwards immigrants
consume fewer welfare benefits than
native born americans and historically
when the us has had an open door policy
there's no evidence that government
spending has been greater than in the
periods when immigration has really been
restricted the last truly major
immigration law was passed in 1986 when
ronald reagan signed bipartisan
legislation that ultimately allowed 2.7
million illegal immigrants mostly from
mexico to gain citizenship since then
reform in washington has proven elusive
indeed like george w bush's promise in
the mid-2000s joe biden's stated desire
to provide a path to citizenship for 11
million illegals has gone exactly
nowhere partly because he's maintained
and in some cases even expanded donald
trump's terrible draconian immigration
policies but even if those immigrants
somehow became citizens overnight
there's no reason to believe they'd
automatically vote for democrats and
produce what representative stefanik
calls that permanent liberal majority in
washington think about this within a few
years of reagan's amnesty program the
gop took control of the house for the
first time in 40 years more recently
between 2016 and 2020 donald trump made
gains with every demographic group
except for white men who's getting
replaced in the 2004 election george w
bush grabbed 44 percent of the hispanic
vote which was just five points off the
49 of the hispanic vote he secured in
the 1998 texas governor race believers
in the great replacement theory might be
surprised to learn that greg abbott won
44 of the hispanic vote in his first run
for the governor's mansion in 2014 and
that texas and florida are not only the
two fastest growing major states but
they are also major magnets for
immigrants and yet keep getting more and
more republican there's at least one
more thing to consider too
representative stefanik and other
replacement theorists routinely invade
against reckless spending and the need
to rein in government spending hooray
i'm with you on that
but here's the thing higher levels of
immigration seem to discourage big hikes
in government spending it was only after
the united states closed its borders in
the 1920s that government spending
ratcheted up sky high and stayed there
as alex nerasta and anderson forrester
of the cato institute have documented
between 1921 and 1968 restrictive
immigration laws cut the percentage of
the population that was foreign born
from 13
down to 4.8
during that same period though the new
deal in great society programs caused
government spending as a percentage of
gdp to soar from 6.9 percent to 18.9
that's a hike of
174 percent immigration laws were
loosened up in 1968 and the foreign-born
population started growing again
reaching almost 14 in 2017. yet over
that same time period federal outlays as
a percentage of gdp went from 18.9
percent to 20.4
an increase of less than 8 percent what
explains this relative stinginess on the
part of americans americans may have
been more tolerant of spending increases
because closed immigration removed the
politically effective immigrant welfare
queen argument according to narasta and
forrester ironically if proponents of
the great replacement theory really want
to get government spending under control
they'd best start lobbying for more
newcomers including from countries whose
descendants voted in bigger numbers for
donald trump in 2020.